everybody you came here you looked
disappointed this is the second time it
happens your opponent comes with just
absolutely incredible preparation and
takes uh the game all the way until the
end like what are your feelings right
now yeah I need to stop playing such
forcing lines this line I even the final
position I remember I can do some moves
I can try but I wasn't able to remember
all the details and like this kind of
position where you're down to Queen like
I was worried that okay I might end up
in like some slightly worse like at some
point uh in my analysis like black plays
A5 apparently y equals A4 yeah at the
right moment if that goes Queen E8 like
during the game I was worried that maybe
I might get into some slightly
uncomfortable positions but of course
it's
but yeah I wasn't able to remember all
the details of otherwise I would have
played and it's just very very difficult
to make any progress at that point yeah
it goes Queen B8 and just stays like
this you stay like that and there's not
much progress for either side yes at
least my game with Brandon like even
though he was prepared all the way it's
the fact that he was playing all those
moves instantly was actually making me
feel better as I was playing all the top
engine moves even that kind of position
because I remember like after I went
back and checked there was a game
between uh
Newton newy and Thai Thai Divan versus
uh yeah that's all right yeah and he
didn't find E6 Bishop for so it kind of
made it made me feel better that okay
I'm able to find such such good
resources so that gave you some
confidence in your play I mean you
showed it yesterday in that critical
moment uh you could repeat the moves
with only a few seconds on the clock and
you chose to go Rook to E8 get out of
repetition and that actually
incentivized the mistake from Andrew uh
how did you come up to with that
solution in that particular Moment In
the Heat of the battle Yeah that game
was very interesting for the the first
move itself was a very very big decision
to make whether I stick with bandaidorf
or I prepare something altogether
different and I decided that okay my
game with Brandon ended like three hours
four hours early so I decided that okay
we have I have a lot of time I decided
to prepare French from the black side so
that because I knew that Andrew is a
very good dietitian so I decided to take
him out of his comfort zone and get a
game so you prepared a new opening in
like a day yeah yeah sir how many months
did you have to prepare your openings
for before you actually played them
months years
a day out of here
how about we prepare the French coach
let's do that
difficult rounds definitely you would
have liked to get more with white pieces
but you definitely get some positive
energy from yesterday game as well and
you're still in the league most likely
depending on what the other results are
yeah sorry this game it was very it was
very interesting I said like around this
point where you went Knight F7 I I felt
that I should be better but it turns out
whenever I played is the best solution
and if I don't like I felt during the
game that like when we both got down the
last 30 seconds I started playing
terrible moves but it turns out like
whatever I did if I don't do those
things engine already says like plus two
plus three it's very it's a very sharp
position and it turns out I did I played
well definitely playing well so far I'll
be money congratulations thank you we'll
see you in a couple of days after the
rest day thank you Mishra I have a
question for you if you don't mind first
of all a comment uh thank you yesterday
very very much I think it was inspiring
what you did courageously playing for
the win and issuing the repetition but I
wanted to ask you about your preparation
because it seems to me that you're
putting an enormous amount of study into
your opening play is that what is
required for you to get to the 2700
class that you're improving your
openings
getting to 2700 is a very difficult task
it consists of a lot of other things
other than openings if you get good
positions you need to convert you need
to convert them and yeah mostly mainly
I've been I've been trying to work on
all aspects of the game
but yeah my openings I I still need to
improve because as of now as
just about everyone has said I'm very
predictable
very predictable well they're not going
to say that about you too long if you
play new openings after one days of
preparation good luck in your campaign
enjoy your free day and we'll see you uh
Friday right right